course this was an arrest like no other
and now he's been granted bail Cordelia
bring us up to speed
yes it's been an incredibly dramatic few
days Imran Khan arrested at the high
court just a few days ago then yesterday
the Supreme Court ruled that that arrest
was unlawful the case then went to the
high court this morning here in
Islamabad where lots of his supporters
have been Gathering outside and we have
just heard the news that Imran Khan has
been granted two weeks bail now that of
course will be very positive news the
news that he was waiting to hear that
the many who have come here to Islamabad
wanted to hear as well it's been a
tumultuous time for all involved this
huge legal battle surrounding that
arrest or remember those striking images
of seeing the Pakistani paramilitaries
taking him from the high court onto the
back of the van and he has been in
custody ever since he had the
opportunity yesterday to speak to uh
some family members but he was
ultimately in the custody of the Supreme
Court now he will be free to roam if you
like we will have to wait and see what
he does next but as I understand it from
his party the PTI there is a plan for
him to address his supporters we've seen
as some very intense protests breaking
out throughout the country people
enraged by what they feel has been
unjust the Supreme Court uh also a ruled
that they felt that it could have a
chilling effect this kind of arrest and
ultimately Justice was not being served
but this is not the end of the story
because Imran Khan faces
127 cases against him of contempt of
court and Corruption as well are just
half an hour ago I was hearing news of a
potential rearrest by Punjab police lots
of worry inside car Camp around that and
there certainly is the possibility that
he may move from here and be rearrested
for another charge so plenty of Jeffy
potentially still ahead but nevertheless
for now at least he is able to walk free
nonetheless Cordelia it is fever pitch
isn't it um Mr Khan does enjoy
significant support across the country
he survived an assassination attempt
it's going to take a lot to calm
everything down
yes you know these are really Vibra
political times here and the economy is
struggling got in inflation plummeting
foreign reserves as well the countries
recovering from those awful floods a
year ago as well and this is an election
year so things really are quite tense
and we've seen these pitch battles
between the government the military
establishment Imran Khan's party as you
say he does enjoy popular support I
spoke to the information Minister last
night as we heard the news from the
Supreme Court
she said we will have to wait and see
where this goes but did defend the
arrest take a listen to what she had to
say do you recognize that there are
peaceful people that believe
the way that Imran Khan was arrested was
unlawful unacceptable a stain on the
country I did not see those peaceful
peoples on the streets in last three
days there are ways to arrest somebody
tell me calmly tell me how peace
no the person as I said a person who
defies law of the land and it if it's
not Imran Khan if it's anybody I ask you
the question in your country also a
conduct of a person is as such what will
the police do
the information Minister also vehemently
denied that this arrest first of all had
anything to do with the government
itself but also said that it wasn't an
attempt to silence Imran Khan
politically that this is just about the
rule of law she also heavily criticized
some of the violence that we have seen
breaking out in In Pockets across the
country we've seen military
installations set fires she said they
are terrorist acts and completely
unjustified others you speak to here say
are they just exercising their
Democratic right to oppose an arrest
that they have always claimed is
unlawful well today now Imran Khan can
enjoy two weeks on bear I'm sure we will
see in the hours to come his attempt to
share his view to redirect his
supporters and to Rally his troops
yeah we are expecting to hear from Imran
Khan later on this morning we will of
course bring you that as soon as he
speaks um in the meantime the
information Minister that you spoke to
the Cordelia
um she flat out denied that the
government is trying to disqualify Mr
Khan from being able to stand in the
elections later this year is that a
realistic prospect that he just won't be
able to stand
uh well she said that's absolutely not
something that they are looking at and
the electron will take place uh later on
in the year but I think what we could
potentially see is weeks and months of
this legal cat and mouse game where
various uh charges which are brought
against Imran Khan he has questioned uh
potentially detained once again and we
will have to see the Fallout from that
as well because you've got these kind of
deeply polarized atmosphere where Imran
Khan supporters are absolutely convinced
that the government and Military
establishment are out to get him
and the government is just saying that
it's trying to pursue important legal
cases
they also have had a kind of tit-for-tap
between
Imran Khan for many years they accuse
him of arresting their own party when he
was in power so it's hard to see any
immediate resolution inside